but is it worth the fight with a voice
that isn't his but a message that is
this was the pre-launch teaser for a man
who wants voters to believe he is the
future for America
well this is where it all began for the
man who wants to be president Daytona
Beach in Florida is Rhonda Santa's old
congressional district it's where his
political roots are and we've come to
find out what the Allure is whether that
Landslide vote for governor back in 2022
really can take him to the White House
[Applause]
America Florida is his line the question
is can he and what would that look like
if I was to say Rhonda Santos to you
what what words come to you come to mind
you love him why
because I think he's he's doing the
things that most of us would like him to
do bigoted
white supremacist
um
Trump want to be nothing wrong with him
he does what what should be done I
believe we fight the woke in the
legislature we fight the woke in the
schools we fight the woke and the
corporations we will never ever
surrender Florida is where wolf goes to
die
if there is one theme which gets to the
heart of what Rhonda Santos is all about
it is the culture War
tapping deeply into a view that America
has lost its way and needs to return to
traditional conservative values whether
that's abortion banned after six weeks
drag shows no children allowed and then
there's books in schools my body is
growing this is for 48 year olds it
talks about sexual intercourse and very
in-depth not in just a biological way
it's just not appropriate for 48 year
olds Tina deskovic co-founded mums for
Liberty now with branches Nationwide he
takes action you know we are tired in
our country and in our state of
spineless leaders who change their mind
who flip flop who go with the flow what
we saw with Governor DeSantis is he
looked at facts and he made decisions
even though they were unpopular this
will be the bitter Battle of the months
ahead once allies make America great
again now not so much the problem with
Rhonda sanctimonious is that he needs a
personality transplant both want to be
the next Republican president both share
the same ideals but is De Santa's Trump
without the chaos a man who could
deliver his conservative policies
exciting or frightening in a bitterly
divided country Mark Stone Sky News in
Florida